no question that moms are struggling
many of them struggling mentally from
winter blues to navigating
with all the kids activities at home
kirsten joyce joining us with some
advice for those still facing this
challenge it's been quite a year for
parents
certainly has brian and the new york
times has been writing some in-depth
articles on moms who had to leave the
workforce stay home with the kids when
school's closed
it also created a primal scream line
this is a phone number for any of you to
call and vent in any way you want
here's a snippet the floor is yours
to yell laugh cry or vent for a solid
minute
i just wanted to say
i'm so sick of my
kids this pandemic has made me realize
that
maybe i'm not cut out to be a mother i
am doing my sixth load of laundry today
oh god every day i think
i can't do this again but then i do i
get it i get up and i do it because
that's just what parents do right
right it's unrelenting it's overwhelming
hang in there moms you're getting
through
now we caught up with dr claire nicosia
a clinical psychologist who says there's
something really significant
about hitting the one-year pandemic mark
what we've gone through is like a global
pandemic that's created a grief response
that we're mourning the way that we
lived our lives we were mourning the way
that
we were able to show up at work and our
kids were able to show up at school and
all those activities and connections
with family and friends
so i think that there's this incredible
loss and
here we are a year later and we still
have so much uncertainty and i think
that's what mentally
creates more psychological distress for
some people
here are some tips dr nickagossian says
acknowledge what you're feeling even if
it doesn't sound good
but she says this isn't the time to
dwell in negative self thoughts get
those out of your head
highlight your strengths and don't
evaluate every single day look at the
bigger picture of life you were getting
through this
most importantly look after your own
mental health carve out at least 10
minutes a day to do something for
yourself
she just published a book called mama
you are enough which has tips for those
struggling there's also an audio version
as well because really who has time to
read books
and if you need that number one more
time for the primal scream line there it
is
two one two five five six thirty eight
hundred just
let it out moms coming from a working
mom her